the most enjoyable story of the day is
the targeting of margaret atwood so
margaret atwood of course wrote the
wildly overrated
sci-fi dystopian novel handmaid's tale
right she was used as the the
sort of
icon of the trump era because of course
trump here was all about sexism okay so
margaret atwood made a mistake what was
her mistake
she tweeted out aps called why can't we
say woman anymore
because all sorts of people on the left
have decided that wokeness must take
into account the fact that men give
birth now if you're a rational person
you're like nope that is not a thing if
men gave birth that would be very
difficult as it turns out to press a
baby through a urethra or through a
butthole it turns out that's very
difficult to eject a baby through either
of those orifices you actually need a
female vagina in order to make that
happen okay but if you point that out
then people on the left go nuts margaret
atwood pointed that out
and so the left came after her which is
quite enjoyable she was a feminist icon
until she assumed that women existed
whoops
so mix amanda jete knox tweeted i'm
disappointed you shared this because
it's factually untrue we can still say
woman and we can also say people when it
makes sense to use more inclusive
language i'm non-binary i also
menstruate and gave birth to three kids
saying people with period periods
includes women and me
um
no you're a woman you're not non-binary
i'm sorry to tell you this that
non-binary is not a category unless you
are actually intersex you're not
non-binary you are that that's in your
head you're a person who menstruated and
gave birth to children you're a woman
done
tanya tuggak tweeted out i didn't know
margaret atwood sucked transphobia sucks
the people commenting on her post should
be enough proof you're the one on the
wrong side of history please glob don't
let me become a harmful crone everyone
call me out when i get crusty and these
are these are delightful delightful
human beings so it is uh it's exciting
stuff to watch them just erase margaret
atwood now she's she's crossed the
cancel culture and the cancel culture
will come after her by the way at
netflix the netflix co-ceo is already
starting to walk back his support for
dave chappelle he said he screwed up in
his efforts to communicate with
employees who were overset over dave
chappelle's new special
he said in an interview quote what i
should have done is led in those emails
with humanity i should have recognized a
group of our employees was really
hurting
[Music]
to be clear storytelling has an impact
in the real world sometimes quite
negative
we have articulated to our employees
there are going to be things you don't
like they're going to be things you
might feel are harmful but we're trying
to entertain a world with varying tastes
and varying sensibilities and various
beliefs and i think the special was
consistent with that
okay so he's already backing up
and so the alternative to bad economics
from the left is bad social policy from
left and here's the thing nobody likes
that stuff this stuff is not
particularly popular the only people it
is popular with
are people who wish to delude themselves
into believing that they are victims in
american life
and if you wish to delude yourself into
believing that you're a victim in
american life you can do it i mean a
huge number of people listen the
incentive structure in human thinking is
always to believe that you're a victim
of outside circumstance and that
whatever hardships you experience in
life have nothing to do with you and
nothing to do with reality they simply
have to do with other people
discriminating against you
and there's a new gallup poll that kind
of demonstrates this
it says that women's satisfaction with
the treatment of their gender in the
united states is now at a record low
apparently only 44 of women say they are
satisfied with the treatment of women in
society 44
and now i just i'm going to point out
here that women in american society are
treated better than women in any society
anywhere on earth for all of human
history
just as an example
right now here are doctoral degrees by
field and gender in
okay in education women outnumber men 68
to 32
overall in all fields doctoral degrees
women out number men 53 to 47
in master's degrees women outnumber men
six to four okay they outnumber them 60
to 40 percent
women outnumber men in total graduate
school enrollment
59.7 to 40.3 percent
and yet women are saying that they are
wildly mistreated in american society so
again the left is trying to say that
we've got this economic plan don't pay
attention while we restructure
everything
also we have this woke plan to take
control of your life but we will give
you a perception of victimhood okay well
if you choose to buy into that then i
suppose you can i just don't think it's
going to make for a very happy life i
think in fact it's going to make for a
very unhappy life but maybe that's the
point you can be on you can be happy in
your unhappiness maybe that's what the
left is is finally betting on here you
can be happy with the breadlines as
bernie sanders suggested you can be
happy with the belief that you're a
victim in a society where you clearly
are not one or you can be an empowered
human being making individual decisions
that make your own life better and the
people in your community make their
lives better as well those are your
choices there's no third choice
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe